et autres manifestations prévues cet
après midi à paris plusieurs
associations en soutien à la cause
palestinienne se réunissent pour un
cortège entre barbès et châtelet une
mobilisation qui intervient quatre jours
avant la présentation par israël de sa
stratégie de mise en place du plan de
paix américain selon washington je cite
l'annexion de la cisjordanie revient aux
israéliens paris de son côté menace de
reconnaître la palestine et ce alors que
l'état hébreu a mené des frappes sur la
bande de gaza cette nuit en représailles
à des tirs de roquette la veille et dans
ce gîte et le géopolitologue emmanuel
dupuy président de l'ihh ps l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
bonjour emmanuel dupuis
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur arte france une manifestation
donc cet après midi en soutien à la
palestine
à quatre jours de l'annoncé par benyamin
nétanyahou
ce sera mercredi quel écho cette
mobilisation peut-elle avoir à
l'international a déjà cette
manifestation s'inscrit dans un vaste
mouvement de protestation internationale
et également israélien il faut avoir à
l'esprit que les israéliens manifestent
déjà depuis début juin contre cette
annonce
ouh la la supposée annonce qui devrait
advenir d'ici quatre jours les débats
sont intenses au sein de la société est
également au niveau politique et
israéliens pour savoir si oui ou non le
président le premier nice pardon mais
jamais des terriers ou va mettre en
application une partie du plan de paix
qui avait été proposé il ya de cela
quelques mois par les américains cette
manifestation française est symbolique
elle est d'autant plus symbolique comme
vous l'avez rappelé que la position
française est apparu un petit peu plus
offensif ces dernières heures
non seulement en menaçant ou en tout cas
en évoquant la possibilité de
reconnaître la palestine mais surtout en
mettant un certain nombre d'états
préalable à sa geste la suspension des
importations la suspension d'un certain
nombre de programmes
opération et kestrel la tension avec
israël n'est pas la seule raison de
cette mobilisation il faut aussi avoir
l'esprit que la position arabe n'est pas
tout à fait unifié par rapport à
l'annexion de maintenant 40 % des
territoires de la cisjordanie et que
c'est aussi un appel à ce qu'il y ait
une mobilisation des puissances
régionales avant tout mais de parler de
ne pas rire qui menacent donc par la
voix de son chef de la diplomatie un
jean yves le drian de reconnaître la
palestine en cas d'élection quel est le
poids réellement de la france à
l'international
sachant qu'en ce moment un pari préside
ce mois-ci le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu alors la france préside que pour
hamoir et ensuite ce sera remplacé par
l'allemagne qui non seulement présidera
le conseil de sécurité mais également la
présidence assumera la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne donc je
pense que le poil allemands est
légèrement supérieure aux lois
françaises
la présidence française est largement
entamée quasiment fini du reste je ne
suis pas certain que la france
d'ailleurs et une position univoque
la position européenne est au diapason
d'appel sont français tous les pays
européens sont d'accord sur l'idée selon
laquelle cette annexion de encore une
fois 40% 30 à 40% des territoires de
cisjordanie avec la reconnaissance les
états unis l'ont déjà implicitement
reconnu de le 400e le fait de
reconnaître la colonisation et donc
l'établissement de 450 mille colons
israéliens dans ces guides territoire
remet en cause aussi fondamentalement le
jeu politique internationale et
notamment eu en fait que si le plan de
paix et mener à bien
c'est non seulement l'annexion de la
cisjordanie qui est préoccupante et
l'annexion la vallée du jourdain qui
remet en cause un des deux d'accord
l'israël l'enact finalement signé que
278 avec l'egypte et en 1195 aka
jordanie et cela remet en cause un très
fragile équilibre dans la région c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle le poids
de la france et la position française
reflète une grande préoccupation
en tout cas de haut niveau du continent
européen mais de parler de fragile
et
situation fragile du côté du
proche-orient justement l'onu la ligue
arabe à paris on vient de le dire
s'opposent à cette annexion si benyamin
nétanyahou persiste et signe
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
jeudi au lendemain de son annonce c'est
ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
conséquences avec une flambée de la
violence au proche orient avec des
conséquences également au niveau de la
scène diplomatique mondiale à quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre alors les
conséquences ne sont pas immédiates mais
elles seront beaucoup plus latente
premièrement il y aura sans doute une
mobilisation au niveau du de la ligue
arabe la ligue arabe a étonnamment une
position unifiée en tout cas ça fait
bien longtemps qu'elle n'en a pas eu les
gars à la question libyenne et la
question syrienne qui ont divisé ses
membres en tout cas je pense qu'il y
aura une sorte de front unifié qui se
recompose rats vis-à-vis d'israël
première éléments plutôt immédiat le
deuxième élément ou plutôt latents ou en
tout cas qui prendra un petit peu plus
de temps c'est de savoir si la décision
israélienne ému processus électoral
américain qu'ils craignent avant tout
c'est à dire le fait de perdre leur
principal et en la personne de donald
trump
on sait que le président le le jir
l'ancien du trident joe biden avait
implicitement reconnu comme l'avait fait
les états unis en décembre 2010 est le
fait que tu aies la ville soit capitale
d'israël mais sans aller plus loin et il
n'a pas du tout la même vision vis-à-vis
du plan de paix proposé dont par le
gendre du prédateur président donald
trump donc sans doute qu'il y aura des
conséquences d'ici quelques mois au
moment où se jouera l'élection
américaine
et puis sans doute aussi qu'il y aura
des conséquences vis-à-vis d'autres
partenaires périphériques à la zone je
pense notamment à la russie qui joue un
rôle de plus en plus important et qui
est sans doute puisque les palestiniens
ne veulent plus discuté ni avec les sera
est venu avec les états unis un
partenaire avec lequel il faudra compter
qu ici les prochaines semaines ces mots
de la fin merci emmanuel dupuis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'épaisseur
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe